[拍手]
[音楽]
古山が今からお話をさせていただきたいなと思うんですけど自分あの
2011年くらいですかねどっかのタイミングで
テレックスみたんですよその時にやべえなこれ
俺もでてーなーみたいなと思ったんですよねそうしたらなんと
でれています
素晴らしい
なんでくるらしいんですかねぇ
それを今日は伝えたいなぁと思ってじゃっはならないですけど
テレックスの運営メンバーがやばいこいつを登壇させて失敗させて失敗したなみたいな
ことを言えるようなことを言っていきたいなと思うんですけど
はい
夢を叶えることは簡単です
今自分がここに立ってます
テレ区
当たってみたいな
建てたんです自分みたいな今日あの皆さん数5 input あると思うんですよ
沢山のインプットあるんですけどここは箸休め何で箸安めです狩り的な存在だと思って
聴いてもらえれば思うんですけど
なんで自分はこの夢を叶えることは簡単かっていうとちょっと自分の
どういうことを活動してるかっていうのを話しながら
説明をしたいなと思っています
最初は自分は
宮城県石巻というところ生まれです
石巻までですずーっと高校時代
石巻にいてとうてつもなく一緒に分け月上がったんですよ
なんだべなおい何したらいいんだろうな全然親父こともねーし
よしそうだ東傾向みたいなよくあるじゃないですかそれって統計たんですよ自分で東京
行って
すごい刺激を受けたんですよやばいめっちゃくちゃ面白い人とかそれは成功してるか
失敗しているかは別として
めっちゃくちゃチャレンジしている人たちがいっぱいいたんですよねそういうような
背中を見てやばい俺も何かやろう
やってやろうと思ったんですね
そこで自分は何かしたいなぁと思ってまぁ web の会社を立ち上げたんですけど
まあいろいろ楽しいこといろいろやらせていただきましたそこで震災があって
石巻に戻って自分はその石巻この街なんかしてやりたいなとこの石巻という町で最高に
遊んでみたいなと思って
今目標を立てていますそれが
ん
石巻を世界で一番テクノロジーが学べる街にする
これが自分のミッションです
簡単ですよ夢叶えるなんて
あとでやり方を教えます最初なんで自分が立ち上げこういうことを思ったかというと
自分はそういう it というところで先ほど
大外にて東京に出てすごい色んなことを勉強させてもらいました
その時にパソコン1台あればもしかする世界変えられるんじゃないかな
思ったんですよパソコンが無くたって世界変えられるんですよ
その時じゃあ自分がまず何をやろうかなと思ったときに
まず一番最初にやったことが
とりあえずしたいした事務所をみんなで直して
みんなっていいからせません最初自分一人だけだけだったんですけど
なおしてまー10人程度でもちょっと少ない数から本当にがっちりプログラミングを
学びたいとイトナブ自分たちとなるという団体は小学生大学生に小学生から大学生に
プログラミングを教えている団体です
みんなに教えるんじゃなくて俺が世界のてっぺんに取るんだというような若者に
とっぷり教えたかったんですよ
だったらまあ10人ぐらいでもいいだろう鉄塔製品木そんな実行屋内死んだよっていう
ような形で一番最初
たかだか10畳ぐらいですかね本当に10人中に入ったら救急なところで始めました
そこから始まった人鍋
今ではやっぱりちょっとずつ仲間が増えてきて
これは2016年去年グループデート言われる
イトナブで毎年年末にある発表会です
石巻の若者たちがこの一年間どういうようなプログラミング
なったかどういうことが瀬川が上がったかというようなことを
紹介するグループデート言われるまあぶっちゃけちゃうとあのてぃ x パクってん
ですよ
みたいな感じのまあ mac じゃんですかこれああいうのを作ったりとか
パクってやってんですよそういうようなことをやってやってたりしてそうやって
若者たちは育っていってますただか最初本当にひとりから始めた
団体が今今なく大きくなります
た毎年やっている自分たち石巻ハッカソンといわれる
ハックとマラソンを掛け合わせた開発イベントですね
限られた時間でどういうことをやろうかとか
どういう成果物が上がろうかというようなイベントがあるんですよハッカソンといわ
れる
そのハッカソン石巻ハッカソンというようなイベントを2012年からやらせて
いただいています
一番最初たかだか
30人くらいだったイベントだったんですけど去年
160人
集まったイベント2012年から始まって
2013201420152016どんどん人が増えていっています
この石のキャット村は
石巻で自分のも今日は300人を集める開発イベントに育てていきたいと思っています
今これだけハッカソンというのは全国的に広まっているイベントの中でどんどん
どんどん大きくなっているイベントなおかつ継続的にやってるイベントは
なかなか少ないですそれが一種のわけですよ
すごい嫌だかどうするっ
まあはそれほどでもないですよ
そういうような形で自分たち自分は何かやりたいなあとか何か夢があったりとか
夢こういうことをしたいと思ったときにまず動き出します
去年石巻の若者たち240名以上に教えました
これって
今どの自治体でも若者教育プログラミングって言っている中で石の家しないですよ
240名
240名にとりあえずあのみんなすごいやつじゃないですよ
それはあのそこのおいて皆とりあえずアプリ1本ずつぐらい作ってますからね
小学生から大学生です大学生だけじゃないですよ石巻
大学1個しかないですから高校生中学生小学生
特に高校生が一番多いです
何かやりたいなと思ったらなんでもできちゃうんですよ
自分が一番最初言った世界の学びの場にしたい
今年シリコンバレーとミシガンの学生が10人ほど1か月人が分
学びに行きます
以前先生
そうなんですよできるんですよ
庶民派ですよこれでも分
そうなんですよ何でもできるんですよ
なんか松岡修造見たくなってきましたねやればだけみたいなそうですね
ポケモンゴー遺書の消え
すごくなったんですよ1週間で10万人の来場者数と
20億円の経済効果
仕掛け人です
できるんですよ
ポケモンが20億円ですよ経済効果
毎夏に前
ポスター作ったりとかステッカー作ったりとか
ホント好き勝手趣味なんでほとんどできるんですよ
この間やっぱり学生たちと触れ合う機会が多いのでよく言われる事が悩んでる
どうしたいかいわかんない夢って何ですかねっ
いやなめんなよと俺だって夢まだわかんねーよみたいな
いやそうですよね死ぬまで一生走り続けると思うんですよね
そろってもう先見えています
未来見えてます未来わかる日ドラえもんいますかいないですよね未来見えてます未来
って見えないんですよ
だからこそみんなやみくもに走るんですよでもまず走る方向
今考えています
考える暇があったら走りましょう
自分が夢を簡単ですっていうのは一ついつも心がけている3つのことがあるんですよね
それが
今日はちょっと伝えたいなという本当のことです
3つの必要なこと
まず1個目
やっぱり夢っていうのはまず持たなきゃいけないな夢って実際持たなくてもいいんです
よ
なんでもいいですよ例えば今日の夜ご飯食いたいな
有名じゃないですかかなえられますよすぐですよね
なんでもいいですよなんでもいいですよ
本当にまず思い続けましょう夢って思い続けることがいう重要なんですよ
まずこういうことをした変な話やべ任天堂スイッチ欲しいなぁ任天堂スイッチ欲しいな
任天堂スイッチ欲しいなと思い続けてください
そうするとそうするとは言わないまず思い続けることが重要です
そしたら思い続けた夢を次に何をしなければいけないかというと
いろんな人に語ってください俺の夢はこうなんだよね俺ノック夢はこう私の夢は江南
こういうことをしたいんだよねこういうことをやりたいんだよね
いやこういうことを考えているんだけどどう思うどんどんどんどん言ってみましょう
言ったらどうなるかというとまず自分に強迫観念が生まれてやべーやんなきゃいけない
な
誰かに言っちゃったからやんなきゃいけないなってあっちゃうんですよね
それって重要だと思うんですよでなおかつ言い続ければおれオレそれできるよとかやっ
てるよとかってそういえば友達にこういうことをやってる奴いるよみたいな
出てくるんですよねだからこそ夢は思うことと語ることは重要です
思って祝祝祝祝てやってはい完成ですって言ったら
できなかったときには誰にも実は何もやってなかったようですから鶴井じゃないですか
言わなきゃいけないですでも言ったからにはやらなければいけないんですよ
そこにつながってくるんですよね
やっぱりそうするとあとは
もう一つ大切なこと最後のやり続ける
4日よくあるんですよ
いやちょっとお金がつきました後
いや実はなんかいろいろ
あってみた家庭環境がみてるいやそういうのどうでもいいじゃないですか
ダームんそういう環境でもやり続けることができるんですよ細々だっていいんですよ
どんだけ家インパクト求めています
自分は石巻で若者たちに
世界一の人間になってもらいたいと思ってますけど極論から言えば10年間石巻で
プログラミング教室つを
まあ教室まで行かなくてプログラミングを教える環境をつくったとしてもたった一人で
いいんですよ
たった一人で1人が世界一になれば石巻からたった1人が10年間で世界一なれば
石巻へ位
金変わりますよだってビルゲイツとかあのマークザッカーバーグとか
ジョブズみたいな人も一緒の時に一定て来て君といくださいエロやばいっすよみんな着
たくなるじゃないですか
みんな多分会社近くに置いておきたくなるじゃないですかそれですよ
何100人とか星人とかイベントで100人集めなきゃいけない
いやいいじゃないですかもしかすると今日のテックスだって一人だ
ために12の登壇者がいたっていいんですよ目的なんですよ
やりたいことをどういうことをしないかというだからこそやり続ける
仙台駅で今日誰か1人でもいいんで終電までずっと踊っててください
やり続けるいえなぁ目的はないですよ何もないですけど
いうことをやること
そこってほんと重要だなと思ってるんですね
自分は
さっきも言ったように夢があるんですよ
石巻で
専任の it 技術者を育てるそして
石巻が世界の it の学びの中心地にする
たった一人で始めた
イトナブ今はこれだけ沢山の賛同者仲間たちが増えてきています
本当にありがたいです自分は能力ほんと何もないですよ
今日の登壇者の中で青本当に確実に箸休め的なウェブサイトみました
一番先ポケモンゴーって書いてありますよねこれ何度車を何度しゃべればいいのかなと
思ったんですけどそんな奴でもここに立てますし
何でもできるんですよそこはただ単純に一つ
いい続けるやり続ける語り続ける思い続ける本当にそういう
想いだけで人は動きますし変わりますし
それにみんな付いてきますだからこそ
何かをやりたかったりとか
どうかしたいとか悩んでる悩む暇があったら
まだせませんあのもう大人の方々はちょっと効かないといただけなんですけどまだ若い
です
走りましょうよコケたって怪我したってまだ浅いすよ
背負ってる荷物軽いですから大人になればどんどん重くなってコケたらほんとに大変に
なりますよ
でも今はコケたって言いたくないですし
たかだか何千万の借金作ってよく言うじゃないですかいいじゃないですか
バイトして頑張って稼いで愛せば何でもなんとかなるんですよ
だからこそやり切りましょうよ
自分は
やっぱり夢は
あって
それに向けて走っていく
ここから石巻が
変わっていくんだよ
やりきりますんで皆さん是非見ててくださいありがとうございました
[拍手]